[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
breaking news the former Italian Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi has died at
the age of 86.
also this American companies say they're
losing confidence in investing in the UK
where she soon that calls for Britain to
become a global leader in business
technology investment as London Tech
week gets underway
a Rebrand for the former UK arm of
Silicon Valley Bank as HSBC unveils its
new tech banking plans
plus new research suggests students want
a wider range of Technology subjects at
school including Esports
[Music]
thank you
good morning this is inkling live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City where we start this
out with some breaking news the former
Italian Prime Minister Silvio Berlusconi
has died the 86 year old media Tycoon
had been treated in hospital for a lung
infection linked to Chronic leukemia he
led the country three times from 1994 to
95 2001 to 2006 and
2008-2011 during his last term in office
Italy came close to a Greek style debt
crisis and he faced numerous scandals
most notably around his notorious bunga
bunga parties our Europe correspondent
Adam Parsons has been taking a look back
at his life and career
he was impossible to ignore Silvio
Berlusconi was a giant figure in Italian
life for decades on end in politics
business Sport and on the global stage
his fortune was built on broadcasting he
constructed a media Empire and made a
vast Fortune
he spent some of that on molding AC
Milan into Europe's best football team
and then turned his attention to
politics from the center right he led
four separate governments spending more
time as prime minister than any other
post-war Italian politician we find
but it was never straightforward
Berlusconi was cited in dozens of
criminal investigations mostly around
claims of fraud he said that was
persecution and claimed to have been in
court two and a half thousand times
trouble did follow him remember this
woman a Moroccan dancer nicknamed Ruby
heart stealer
Berlusconi was convicted of paying her
for sex when she was just 17 years old
at one of his lavish bunga bunga parties
they were taking part in a burlesque
competition
and they trained for it because these
women by their very nature are
exhibitionists they are show girls who
like to put on a show and compete
but he won an appeal and laughed off the
Scandal bunga bunga became a catchphrase
not a source of Shame
then came a conviction for tax fraud
that he couldn't beat Berlusconi was at
his lowest air and protested furiously
on one of his own TV stations
in exchange for the commitments I have
made over almost 20 years in favor of my
country and coming almost at the end of
my public life I received as a reward
accusations and a verdict that is
founded on absolutely amazing it takes
away my personal freedom and my
political rights he was a global figure
he hosted three G8 meetings that is a
record
but his brand of diplomacy was eccentric
he famously left Angela Merkel hanging
around while he took a phone call
eventually she walked off
once welcomed a Spanish prime minister
warned me to Italy only to cheerfully
stroll away from their joint scheduled
press conference leaving Jose zapatero
utterly bemused
but Berlusconi was blessed with an
infectious smile
Rolling Stone magazine once named him
their rock star of the year he had
Charisma and he knew how to get in touch
with people and even if sometimes he
could
[Music]
looked like a little bit strange
eccentric but at the end it was a very
friendly person
[Applause]
[Music]
politics once more part of the Coalition
that pushed Giorgio Maloney into power
still a political heavyweight into his
late 80s
Silvio Berlusconi was a man who lived
for the spotlight
I'll joining me on the line as our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins I
mean Siobhan before he became a
politician he was of course one of
Italy's most successful ever business
people a lot of questions about what
happens to his business Empire but I
guess also what happens to Italy's
ruling Coalition of which he was a part
yes so as you say and as Adam was just
reporting there he was a Media Mobile a
billionaire and in the 1970s he created
his first cable TV company and by the
80s uh he was basically ruling the
airwaves here in Italy uh he went on to
invest in a range of other businesses so
having involvement in AC Milan football
club for example in shock influences
then but then of course this huge figure
on the Italian political scene as well
nicknamed the kingmaker role and he had
three different synths uh leading the
country here one of those made him the
longest serving uh prime minister that
Italy has seen and that's despite the
fact that he was linked to so many
scandals of course the infamous bunga
bunga scandals but also a tax fraud
conviction allegations of course as well
and despite the fact that he was 86 he
was still playing a huge part art in
politics he's also Italia party was part
of the ruling Coalition he also was the
senator himself but we have seen his
health deteriorating uh in the last
decade he had open heart surgery and
then since the end of last year there
has really been a marked deterioration
in his health he'd been in hospital for
around six weeks being treated for
complications with leukemia he'd come
out and then on Friday gone back for
what we're told
to see how he was doctors weren't happy
then with the results of the test
decided to keep him in and then today
sources told us that his health really
had deteriorated that his family had
gone to his bedside and it's now been
confirmed uh both by a source within the
hospital but also from local media here
that Silvio Berlusconi has died at the
age of 86.
thanks Yvonne
now Joe Biden and Richie sunac last week
agreed an Atlantic declaration to
strengthen economic ties between the U.S
and the UK but research published today
suggests that U.S companies operating in
the UK are losing confidence in
Britain's business environment the Third
Edition of the transatlantic confidence
index issued by British American
Business and baining Company suggests
High corporate taxes and brexit are the
two factors behind the weakening of
confidence who are joining me now is
Duncan Edwards He's chief executive of
British American Business Duncan morning
to you how many companies did you speak
to here we we spoke to over 80 companies
so 56 large U.S companies that invest in
the UK so it's a most on very large
companies so representing a very good
cross-section of U.S investment into
into the UK economy and this is mainly
down to brexit and corporate taxes
there's a few issues that were
highlighted I think ongoing concern
about the UK's relationship with the EU
and bear in mind this was this survey
was done just after the Windsor
framework was agreed so whether the full
impact of the Windsor framework had
filtered through to Executives thinking
we we probably think it hasn't yet
um but yes so friction with between the
UK and the EU
um
Rising Corporation taxes and in fact the
tax burden throughout the p l of U of
U.S companies that are here and then a
sense that the regulatory burden across
every industry instead of being
alleviated with brexit has actually
increased so
um these are these are concerns I would
say that whilst sentiment is down
Behavior continues to be pretty robust
so U.S companies continue to choose the
UK
um as their preferred place to invest in
the European geography what in reality
can be done about this I mean the
government itself has just imposed all
these high corporate taxes and and no
party is going to be uh brave enough to
call for a return to the EU anytime soon
well I think on on your point about your
right on corporation tax we really do
hope that future governments take a long
hard look at the burden they're placing
on companies that choose to do business
here I also think by the way the
Atlantic declaration that was agreed
last week is a very very positive move
it signals intent by both sides to
negotiate a more liberalized and
coherent environment between the US and
the UK there's a huge amount of work to
be done though to make what was it
essentially a set of intentions into a
set of agreements but we wish them luck
with that well quite so I mean we are
still a long way off a comprehensive
Free Trade Agreement aren't we yeah like
I think we've known for uh for a while
now that certainly under this
Administration in the US there is no
realistic likelihood of a Free Trade
Agreement the that's not on the agenda
not just for the UK by the way but for
any country the US made that very clear
at the start of the Biden Administration
that they they are seeking to invest in
their own economy and they're very
focused on U.S workers and that
prohibits trade agreements obviously
though we've just joined the uh Pacific
Free Trade Agreement dealer CPT PS is
that potentially the way to a backdoor
deal with the US well who knows I mean I
think that everyone was a bit surprised
five years ago when the the US didn't
join the cptpp because they'd been the
driving force behind it and now with the
UK joining that that possibly gives the
US a reason to think again but again I
under this Administration I think that's
extremely unlikely does that change if
Donald Trump returns to office
well certainly I mean for whatever you
think of the the previous president he
was
Keen to negotiate an agreement with the
UK
um and they got pretty close before the
election
um but he also ruled out the cptpp
membership so probably you you shouldn't
hold your breath for that one okay
Duncan good see you this morning thank
you thanks
now today marks the start of London Tech
week a week-long festival celebrating
the best of tech and bringing together
Founders Business Leaders policy makers
and investors well speaking at the event
in the last few minutes Rishi sunak said
the government plan to make the UK the
best place in the world for Tech
businesses to Launch
we are an island of innovation but at A
Moment Like This when the tectonic
plates of Technology are shifting not
just in AI but in Quantum synthetic
biology semiconductors and much more
we cannot rest satisfied with where we
stand
we must act and act quickly if we want
not only to retain our position as one
of the world's Tech capitals
but to go even further
and make this the best country in the
world to start grow and invest in Tech
businesses
that is my goal and I feel a sense of
urgency and responsibility to make sure
that we seize it
because one of my five priorities is to
grow our economy
and the more we innovate the more we
grow
well we're going to be bringing you
interviews all week from London Tech
week and to kick things off today we're
going to hear from the co-founder of one
of the businesses that has done most to
reshape the world of work in recent
years and which is now at the heart of
the debate about hybrid working Carl
Henderson is co-founder and chief
technology officer of slack the instant
messaging and collaboration platform for
businesses Cal very good to see you this
morning
um how has the return to the office
changed the way that people are using
Slack
I think when we when we started like
before the pandemic almost a decade ago
we were you know in the in the old
default way of working which meant most
people were in the office every day
um although you know as you look at any
large organization every every
multinational is always being
distributed right and so as we've now as
we went through the pandemic and saw
everybody work from home overnight we
started to see that roll back but it's
definitely the the cat's out of the bag
in terms of how productive organizations
can be when people work from home so I
think we're never going to see a full
reversion today knowledge workers in the
UK offers the national statistics uh
have recently and they're recently
released study show that somewhere
between a third and 40 percent of
knowledge workers in the UK now have a
hybrid setup so working from home at
least some portion of the week and that
demand for that is even higher up as
high as two-thirds so I think while
we've seen a number of people come back
to the office we're never going to go
back to the way we were three or four
years ago now you were bought by
Salesforce just under two years ago for
27b million dollars how difficult is it
being to maintain that kind of startup
mentality now you're part of a great big
corporate you know at the time we were
acquired we were already a sizable
public company with thousands of
employees but definitely joining a
company you know 20 times the size of us
is a very different kind of environment
and I think it's it is as much about
mindset as it is about scale about how
you operate how you think about building
products and bringing them to Market and
how you listen and respond to customer
feedback you know we are a decade old
but still feel like quite a young
company and that the world of work is
changing so much now with the pandemic
and also with the return to real partial
return to office afterwards that I think
there's still a real opportunity for us
to remain Nimble and understand how the
world is changing I think the world of
work is changing now faster than it ever
has before the in some ways the pandemic
you know accelerated that change by
maybe a decade or more kind of overnight
so I think the and the pace of change
with with changes that are even
happening this year I think is only
going to continue now you face a lot of
competition not least from Microsoft
teams I know there's a case going on
that you can't talk about but more
broadly how are you evolving the product
to see off that competition
I think that we're we're trying to look
at uniquely ways in which we can help
support companies in this era as we move
into a much more hybrid role so thinking
about what are the unique
things that are good about being in an
office what are the unique things that
are good about working from home and how
we can bridge that Gap to help
organizations who are hybrid be more
productive I think every organization is
figuring this out right how they can
maintain the level of productivity that
they saw during the pandemic but also
help augment some of the some of the
activities that are just better done in
person we especially see this in
Industries
um like Finance or sales roles where
there's a strong apprenticeship model
and being in the office and and working
alongside people and watching how they
work is a huge part of understanding how
to do the job and I think features that
we've we've added in the last couple of
years in slack include things like
huddles which is a a very easy way to
just start an audio conversation with
somebody immediately the equivalent of
walking up to them in the office and
tapping them on the shoulder so I think
it's how can we think about features and
kind of experiences that replace what's
great about being in the office but you
still get the opportunity of hybrid and
that strong demand that people have for
flexibility in time and location where
they work and what about AI I I think AI
is really really interesting I think
it's in some ways this kind of
acceleration that we've seen in kind of
work changing is going to continue
because of AI I think it's still very
early days we don't understand quite the
impact that it's going to have but
definitely the thing that's most
interesting in the workplace is can it
continue to accelerate individual
productivity and if just one company had
these AI uh you know capabilities then
we'd see them move far ahead and be able
to be far more productive but these are
tools that are available to every
organization so I think we're going to
see every kind of organization of
knowledge workers in every industry
utilize AI to get more productivity out
of their existing Workforce Carl there's
so much more wanted to ask you but
rather Tom I'm afraid come back and see
us again please thank you
some other business news stories for you
now the Swiss banking giant UBS said
this morning it's completed its takeover
of domestic rival credit Swiss well UBS
road to the rescue of its rival in March
in a three and a quarter billion US
dollar deal orchestrated by the Swiss
government aftermarkets lost confidence
in credit Swiss following a series of
mishaps well the final hurdle to the
Takeover was crossed on Friday afternoon
when the Swiss government agreed that it
would backstop UBS to the tune of 10
billion dollars to protect it from any
losses related to the Takeover
the online electrical Goods retailer AO
world and Mike Ashley's retail combine
phrases group said today they were
forming a strategic partnership it comes
after the pair confirmed news broken by
Sky's Mark clyman over the weekend that
frasers had acquired an 18.9 stake in AO
World well that stake was previously
held by OD Asset Management the hedge
fund manager who's founder Chris benody
has been hit by a wave of sexual
misconduct allegations the pair said the
investment was a combination of
productive talks over the last two years
about establishing a strategic
partnership
The Mining and commodity trading giant
glencore has offered to buy the
metallurgical coal business of Canadian
minor Tech resources well the offer
comes after Tech twice rejected a 22.5
billion US dollar approach for a full
takeover of the company arguing it
wanted to be left to pursue its own plan
to split itself into a Metals business
and a separate Coal Company it said last
week it had received several approaches
for its metallurgical coal arm or
metallurgical coals sometimes known as
coke and coal is an essential ingredient
in the steel making process
foreign
[Music]
solid finish on Friday evening during
which the NASDAQ completed a seventh
successive week of gains was followed by
a largely positive session overnight for
equities in the asia-pacific region
again all of the main indices in
positive territory there apart from
Shanghai you can ignore the uh ASX in
the bottom right-hand corner the
Australian Market was closed today for a
public holiday in Europe stocks have
also traded largely to the upside so far
this morning here's the current picture
all the main Continental European
indices doing pretty well they're
talking points today including Novartis
the Swiss drug maker is ahead by some
one percent in Zurich after it agreed to
buy the U.S biotech firm Chanute
Technologies for three and a half
billion US Dollars we're here in London
the ftse 100 is also in positive
territory albeit up by only a fifth of
one percent it's a broad-based rally
right now the leading Blue Chip gainer
in percentage terms is Accardo shares up
per six and a half percent nearly there
it hit its lowest level in a year on
Friday and that looks to have attracted
a few bargain hunters crawling out of
the woodwork on the downside the
industrial Warehouse landlord sea grow
the shares there are off some two
percent on adverse broker comments
outside the ftse 100 the IT Services
Group kanos is up six and three quarter
percent that's all awesome broker Comet
and wizair is up by a 400 or so for
similar reasons to the downside Tallow
oil you can see there on the screen down
nearly one and three quarter percent the
company said this morning it's
considering options for its interest in
Cote d'Ivoire on the foreign exchange
markets well all eyes this week on a lot
of big Central Bank decisions you've got
the uh fed the European Central Bank and
the bank of Japan or making rates
decisions today Sterling up by uh just
over a seventh of one percent right now
against the US dollar it's off by 10 to
1 against the Euro The single currency
meanwhile up a quarter of one percent
against the dollar as for the oil price
well that has continued to drift this
morning amid concerns over global demand
a ballot Brent crude will currently set
you back 72.70 cents a pound that is
down by just over two and three quarter
percent on the session while joining me
this morning is Russ malty's the
investment director at AJ Belle Roscoe
good morning thank you well let's start
with all I mean that's a you know a week
or so ago we have this news from OPEC
that the Saudis want to cut production
again the Market's just brushed it off
that's the second OPEC plus policy move
and production cut in the market hasn't
shown in the interest I guess what's
interesting is the oil Market is saying
there's a global slowdown that's
potentially a recession coming the
equity in stock market is saying
actually no we think everything's going
to be okay thank you very much so on
balance one of them is going to be wrong
you would think and if you're an oil
Trader you've got it wrong it could be
very uncomfortable there's alleged there
are suggestions of a big short position
against oil so if it starts to go up
just will need to buy the oil back to
cover their positions the Americans have
run their strategic for children Reserve
down to its lowest level since 1983 and
if the recession forecast is wrong and
the International Energy agency is
correct and oil demand keeps growing
this year it's actually not that hard to
construct quite a bullish scenario for
oil despite all of the prevailing Gloom
the people who won't want to hear that
Central Bankers with inflation targets
and consumers because they'll be seeing
the price at the pump go back up again
so it's a very very important area oil
and it's nice to see for most people oil
going down but again hope it will
clearly be doing its best to stop it
it's around 70 bucks you met you
mentioned there's a big short position
uh allegedly so yeah we know who's
behind that I think it's just Traders I
think the Wall Street Journal of quoted
a figure of 50 or 60 super tankers worth
which is quite a a an intriguing number
but I think it's about 50 odd it's about
50 million barrels or something like
that allegedly so half a day's
production not enormous but if there's
lots of people looking to close out in a
hurry all those elephants can't get
through the same cat flap that's
fascinating fascinating now let's talk
about some corporate news uh UBS finally
cleared up per credit Swiss today I mean
uh does it's the more this goes on it
still looks like a great deal this for
UBS the price that they've paid you
would assume is sufficiently lower to
protect them against virtually anything
it was what 10 cents on the dollar or
less or something like that I mean there
are clearly lots of hurdles to overcome
when their initial did their initial
accounting the gain that they wrote on
that wrote through and that wasn't as
big as some analysts expected so again
they've covered themselves a little bit
more by not getting too carried away and
interesting coloring some of the
journals today about how ubs's CEO and
Gemini are laying down the law to credit
Swiss Bankers countries they can't deal
with businesses they can't get involved
with to say look you know we I think the
fridge was cultural contamination that
was used which is you know pretty strong
stuff as banking girls so they're saying
look UBS does it this way it's our way
or the highway credit Suite has got
itself in lots of trouble if you want to
keep it keep your job it's now our way
thank you very much indeed yeah now what
about this type between AO world and
phrases yeah I suppose a little bit like
welcome to the new boss same as the old
boss I suppose in the you know Michael
Murray is Mr Ashley's son-in-law but
he's obviously considering with a a
similar process of frankly for first of
all I think probably looking for a
bargain again the shares are down way
from their high they are world I know
they've rallied a bit this year so
there's always that option
um phrases saying it's just a
shareholding it's nothing it's not a
precursor to anything more dramatic like
a takeover so there's the value element
and also you can see why I mean phrases
has got a big white Goods business it's
not the ethnicity where Sports Direct
came from so there's expertise to be had
there and I'm sure there's brand across
um cross fertilization 2 can do as well
when they cooperate now the one thing
that interested me Mark Lyman wrote this
on Saturday and the point is this is a
stake previously owned by Odin now it
feels like to me if I was in there in
the market I'd just be going through
od's portfolio and I've seen what else
they might I'm sure every Trader hedge
fund manager and everything else will be
looking exactly what they've got and
then probably quite carefully either
taking evasive action on moving the
price against them to make life as
uncomfortable for them as they can to
maximize the opportunities that are
available it sounds cruel and it is but
there are no better Investments than
those made from a forced or distressed
seller so it's now up to the Audi Group
whatever the FCA inquiry finds and
however it's handled internally and
these are clearly very serious
allegations it's now up to them to
reassure their investors that it wasn't
a one-person band that there is a strong
process there there is a strong team
there who continues who can continue to
provide the returns that the
organization did under its previous
leadership and if they can't do that
satisfactorily and it's gonna it's gonna
take time then there is a concern that's
clearly some investors may head for the
dot and that's why these stories going
around that there may be some fun
trading suspended while they try and get
things sorted out yeah when the market
smells bloody Russ good to see you this
morning thank you
more from London Tech week as we ask how
the UK can retain its leadership in Tech
investment stay with us
[Music]
welcome back now back to London Tech
week which this week celebrates its 10th
such event that's a testament to the
UK's leadership in Tech UK Tech firms
raised gesture I have 30 billion dollars
in Venture Capital funding last year
making the UK the third largest country
worldwide for Tech investment behind the
US and China but how does the UK retain
that leadership well joining me now is
the chief executive of London and
partners Laura Citra Laura welcome to
you I'm in the UK can't rest on its
Laurels here that's the key message
absolutely and as we go into this 10th
year of London Tech week it's a time for
us to cast our minds back and see what
we've achieved over the last 10 years go
back 10 years
the idea of silica roundabout was still
quite new tech was this nascent industry
it was all about startups in a sort of a
cluster in East London we had about 10
unicorns which is businesses valued over
a billion and today we have over a
hundred we have seen the most investment
into the UK from International tech
companies of any country in the world so
there's lots to be really pleased with
and we should be really proud of our
leadership position but obviously London
Tech week is all about saying okay
what's next yeah you can't talk about
silicon roundabout anymore by the way
Transport for London have just turned it
into a traffic jam 24 hours a day I mean
which of the sectors doing best in Tech
right now so for London the sectors that
are doing really well are those where we
had an established strength and then we
combined it with technology because
that's what London's really good at so
obviously fintech has always been a real
strength because we're a Global
Financial Center some of the creative
Industries Technologies like gaming
immersive we've done really well in
um fashion Tech very strong and Life
Sciences so all the health Tech and
biotech we've done really well the
sector that's really come out of the
blocks in London though over the last
few years is climate Tech so all the
green sustainable Technologies where
we're really emerging as a leading a
leading Center and I think that's really
exciting how worried would you be that
the sort of backlash that we're seeing
against the transition now from some
consumers and business groups is going
to derail that investment
I think we're continuing to see really
strong investment into Green Tech
companies and a lot of what they do is
make it easier for consumers to make the
right choices so two businesses that I
love are Olio where you can give away
free food that's a london-based business
great success story another example from
the circular economy is back Market
originally a French business did a big
expansion into London and that's where
you can buy second-hand computers and
phones so those kinds of businesses are
hopefully making it easier for us to all
live a more sustainable life and that's
how we help people to come on that green
Journey yeah and we've had both those
companies on this program are the sort
of people that are attending this event
changing yes so we're seeing lots more
International visitors which is
fantastic so we've got about 20 000
people coming to London Tech week this
year about a third of those are coming
in from outside the UK and that's
fantastic but it's it's Testament to the
way London there's really this
International Center for technology we
are the dominant European Tech City we
have twice as much VC funds as Paris or
Berlin twice as many unicorns and I
think this week and the scale of
international visitors shows that that
real International nature of London all
right Laura as Lowe's Mo wanted to ask
you but we're right out of time today
really time afraid good to see you thank
you
well during the last hour Richie sunax
been asked at London Tech week about the
resignation as an MP of Boris Johnson
and his controversial honors list here's
what he said
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right that was to
you know either overrule the holak
committee or to make promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
I um well I got this job
when I when I got this job I said I was
going to do things differently because I
wanted to change politics
and that's what I'm doing
well earlier this year we covered the
launch of the third black Founders fund
by Google for startups under which the
tech giant provides funding and for
startups founded by black entrepreneurs
it aimed at addressing the racial
inequality and Venture Capital funding
less than a quarter of one percent of
which went to UK black LED startups in
2020. well today the 10 companies that
will qualify for a total of four million
dollars worth of funding have been named
and joining me now to talk about this is
mariama bumanjal she's Google for
startups black Founders fund manager for
Europe and Africa very good to see you
this morning
um tell me about some of the companies
that have got funding yeah super excited
so today we announced 10 out of the 40
companies so it just shows like 10 other
companies are UK based and not any other
country across Europe and Africa has
actually so many startups represented
and we have um see you from slanger
who's actually using technology to
address the shortage of um Hospitality
workers trying to really connect
Hospitality workers 10.3 million in the
UK alone own with um living wage
opportunities another one is Sarah from
hosmos she is actually trying to write
to make the rental more affordable by
providing tenants with a an insurance
product and we do as well have a lot of
fun my masters she wants to make sure
that athletes
um perform really well on a daily basis
and prevent Insurance
yeah like prevent any uh athletic uh how
do you say
um yeah making sure that they don't
break a leg basically what about uh what
did they have to do to get funding I
mean to be honest this year was a very
tough process we received 4 000
applications wow and of which we gave 40
Equity free grants so it just shows we
shortlisted at 150 interviewed 150 and
then we had an army of googlers senior
googlers across different organizations
uh interviewing
um the founders and then we had a
selection committee that is made out of
the exec leadership GV Google Cloud
sales people who really understand
startups and fundraising and yeah so it
was a really tough process for funders
to get through and to make it to the top
40. and it's not just uh funding and
support from Google that they get I mean
they're getting free air time from ITV
they're getting legal support from Alan
Andover I mean it's quite a
comprehensive package correct I mean
it's really exciting to see that we
launched the fund 2021 and so many other
organizations have either joined us and
partnered with us or actually
um initiated uh launch similar
initiatives where we know for a fact
that funding plus programming is a very
successful combination we do we heard
before that Founders are black founder
specifically are over mentored but
underfunded but now we actually provide
them with funding but at the same time
help them to further grow their
businesses with the best of Google but
then as well through our partners and
what happens after a year
um so uh I mean this is the third time
we're doing it if I look now at the
founders from cohort number one in 2021
so we have for example questionna
Buffett from audiomop uk-based company
and they do audio intrusive gaming and
ads so they now raise their series a
they launch into the US they launch into
the Middle East they created hundreds of
jobs same with Richard Robinson he is
the founder of Robin AI he was tired of
being a lawyer and writing so many
contacts over and over again that he
used AI to create and edit contracts so
he just recently closed the series a as
well and he has right now 75 full-time
employees made out of 30 lawyers
software engineers and he's about to use
a series a to hire another hundred and
to scale again across the US and as well
some other regions so I like you can
really see how when we started working
with them they had less than 10
employees they were just UK based and
now like just two years later we already
seen the huge impact they are having not
only in the UK but as well globally and
does Google end up taking an equity
stake in any of these businesses no we
don't it's Equity free granting we
believe that black Founders are locked
off of access to funding and this is
where we provide them immediate he was
funding that they can use it to hire the
right people and really grow their
businesses and especially hiring
um is one of the key components that the
founders use to the funding for
um and making sure that they have the
right people on the team to help them
grow their businesses good to see you
this morning
foreign
[Music]
look at this morning's business Pages
now and the financial time splashes its
print edition with Nicholas sturgeon's
arrest yesterday but also on its front
page reports that EU funds managed by OD
Asset Management are discussing
restrictions on investors withdrawals as
part of emergency measures to contain
the Fallout of sexual misconduct
allegations against the hedge fund
manager well the times leaves its
business pages with news at two more
forecasters have predicted the UK will
avoid a recession this year it says KPMG
now expects the UK economy to grow by
0.3 this year while the CBI is
predicting an expansion of 0.4 percent
the paper also carries on its business
front page a warning from the National
Audit office that hmrc's delayed program
to digitize the tax system is expected
to cost at least five times it's 226
million pound estimate in real terms
well that story also makes the lead in
the business section of the Daily
Telegraph which also reports that the
billionaire investor George Soros has
handed over leadership of his business
Empire to his 37 year old son Alexander
let's get more now from the sun's
business editor Ashley Armstrong Ashley
welcome to you um you want to talk about
a story that I haven't mentioned at all
yet well yeah I mean there's there's a
lot um kind of packed in the papers this
morning but uh one thing that did catch
my eye was um Catherine Mann has written
an essay uh published by the resolution
foundation and it's really tackling this
thing that we've talked about about
intergenerational tensions and that's
really because Older Workers are
retiring early and she raises the
question of if they're retiring early
and as we know the problems are kind of
productivity labor shortages who's going
to be paying that tax burden and if it
is the young to hire younger workers I
should should stress through hire tax
burdens then that will increase the
tensions even further and I just think
that this is one of those points that
you know we're hearing these debates how
are we going to kind of change the
workforce we know younger workers are
wanting different things and also
retirees have got fairly good lives you
know they've got kind of a different
sort of house wealth than most others
um it's a debate that I think is going
to run and run it really is I mean
you're going to get some people throwing
things at the TV and saying not all
retired people exactly because obviously
there aren't but uh in general the point
holds I mean a lot of it is they've got
very generous final salary pensions
which exactly we haven't yeah no no
that's and that's a big big chunk of it
as well um but also you know there's a
lot to talk about and every time we talk
about mortgage rates we I invariably get
lots of letters saying when I paid my
mortgage it was 15
um and yes mortgage rates were a lot
higher but uh kind of indebtedness was
much lower and also just housing
affordability was much easier then it
was only three times salary rather than
having to save 13 years for for a
first-time buyer and there was also
something called myras mortgage interest
related source which you wrote off
against your tax bill which you don't
have no no so there's all those packs so
I thought that was a really interesting
piece actually also called your eyepiece
and the Ft concerning Hub Group or thgs
yeah well it's sort of a mastermind Pet
Shop check to find THD and all of it's a
major vagaries and flouting of corporate
governance and
um and again you know actually kind of
the shareholder advisory groups ISS and
glass Lewis who are often kind of
criticized for being kind of overly
cautious overly box ticking in their
regard but um they've signaled Ian
McDonald who is known you know as a
major investor in boohoo and other
e-commerce companies
um and said maybe he's not so
independent and I would say no he's not
that independent because you know he's
on LinkedIn pretty much every other week
giving very fawning remarks to molding
the founder and also he tried to buy the
business not not even a year ago with
King Capital so it's um it is
interesting and it's kind of one of
those things that you know we we want to
celebrate and you know as Tech week is
going on we want to celebrate these Tech
entrepreneurs and and you know kind of
make London more attractive but I think
we should also hold on to some of our
standards of governance and you know
call it out when actually
um a boardroom isn't being kind of held
to as much account as it should be all
right Ashley gotta leave it there great
to see us ever thank you
now three months ago HSBC rescued the UK
arm of the failed lender Silicon Valley
Bank buying the business for a symbolic
one pound well today to coincide with
the start of London Tech week it's
unveiled further details on its plans
it's re-christening the business HSBC
Innovation banking the bank also
revealed its high teams of lenders in
the United States Israel and Hong Kong
on top of the 650 staff that came with
svb UK who specialize in lending to the
tech and Life Sciences sectors well the
chief executive of HSBC Ian Stewart
joins Mina chief executive of HSBC UK of
course Ian welcome to you tell me first
of all about these new recruits where
have they come from
well we've we've recruited teams in the
United States in Israel and we are just
finalizing bringing on a team in Hong
Kong as well and these are people who
have been in the Innovation market for a
long time but with the devise of Silicon
Valley Bank we're keen to come and join
Progressive Forward Thinking which I
think we absolutely are at HSBC we're
very excited about the launch day of
HSBC Innovation Banking and it sets out
our stall I hope for the next 10 to 20
years because as I've said to you before
Ian I think we'll be talking about
Innovation and the John 1880 for many
many years to come and they cross over
are you being like a football manager
here Ian and having to sort of bust your
salary structure to get these these
specialist lenders on
oh it's not a great question no we we
are we are trying to be pragmatic but
you know always when you're looking for
good talent you you pay the market rate
to get the best people and we have got
an ambition to hire the absolute best
people we can because as I said just
there I mean we see this as a long-term
play I'm very excited about it we are
too are you mainly targeting startup
series or you're often more mature
businesses in the tech lines Life
Sciences space as well it's really
interesting Ian because this morning the
Prime Minister and the chancellor both
spoke about this so startup funding is
crucially important if you ask any
entrepreneur they'll say that how do I
get the funding but there's also a
challenge today about second third stage
and the way we are positioning the
global business HSBC Innovation banking
globally is we will be there for seed
all the way through to IPO and we think
we are uniquely positioned to do that
and that's what makes the overall
proposition very exciting but yeah
making sure customers and and investors
have got access to Capital is really
important
I advise you this before uh Ian but
let's just see whether you can still hit
hit that note I mean is HSBC
sufficiently culturally attuned to
lending to uh startups
well I've been at so many events and
I've said look please please we we need
we need you to keep and preserve what
you've got and that's exactly what we've
promised to do and in fact the
chancellor said this morning to me it
was it was a trust play in HSBC so I've
given the commitment as has my group
chief executive we will not um let you
down on that trust so let me just
explain what we're going to do we're
still just doing the integration work as
we speak so that's probably going to
take another four five six weeks once
that is done then we've got three phases
in the plan the first one is to protect
what we've bought make sure we preserve
the people the products and look after
our customers the customers expect no
less the second phase is we'll start to
add on all the great products and
services HSBC offer and that's where you
get seed to IPO and that is equally
exciting and then third point is to take
it globally and we've announced that
this morning
um and that that is live today I'll take
a little bit of time to get going but we
have got a global ambition for the
Innovation market and we've set out that
stall this morning
are you going to have to change your
risk models though because a lot of
these businesses have a very different
risk profile from a lot of the
corporates that you traditionally lend
to
yes I mean we we have said we will
preserve what svb did in the market that
means we have got to do that going
forward as part of HSBC Innovation
banking now you are aware in we've got
some car routes from The Ring fence so
we're going to continue to run this part
of the bank separately it's going to
keep its Offices here in London and
Finsbury Square they've just been decked
out in all the new logos and and the
marketing uh material over the weekend
and that keeps its identity it keeps its
culture and we are going to try and work
with that embellish it make it even
better but we have to preserve what we
bought that's a key ingredient of our go
forward plan
look what we've got you uh obviously
last week you paused the availability of
a number of your mortgage products what
was going on there
yeah well Ian thanks for raising that um
let me just explain what happened I'm I
I don't think the media was terrific on
it and it's it's actually not helpful
that people get in use which isn't
accurate so on Thursday we had to pause
for a few hours our mortgage products to
Brokers but let me explain why that
happened we made a commitment right at
this well actually at the tail end of
last year that we were going to help our
customers through this very difficult
period that means we were going to keep
our mortgage rates as low as competitive
as we could
now what happens when you do that is
your products are are in demand and last
week with other products coming off the
market or prices going up we'd made a
conscious decision to hold our pricing
that created a quite significant spike
in demand on Thursday which in honestly
we could not cope with that demand and
if we just say to people yes it's okay
we'll do it then you can't complete on
the paperwork and you end up letting
customers down so we took the decision
that we paused for a couple of hours we
were back open again on Friday and again
we'll have to monitor it so what I would
say is I'm I apologize to the Brokers
I'm sorry if we let you down we could
not cope with that demand but I'm not
going to apologize for trying to look
after our loyal customers and what I
think is a very difficult situation with
rates continuing to increase but we're
here to support our customers throughout
are you actively chasing Market sharing
mortgages right now
well we had we had a lot of market share
come to us last weekend um my first
priority is to look after the customers
who are with us today obviously but we
also want to be you know really good
citizens in the UK economy and if people
do want to join the HSBC family then we
want to make that happen first priority
has to be our loyal customers that we've
got
um wouldn't say I was actively out
chasing hard in the market for all the
reasons that you will understand but
we're here to serve and and we really
must look after people it is I think
quite challenging time
how many of your mortgage customers come
off fixed rate deals this year in
300 000 customers will be impacted this
year
um so it's significant and if you if you
took a mortgage let me say maybe two
years ago or five years ago
um myself included you know um you you
come off our mortgage rate I would guess
around 1.5 percent something in that
area and your new mortgage is going to
cost someone closer to five percent so
this this is this is not a subject to be
flipping on this is a very very
important topic in UK society today and
what we're trying to do HSBC is try our
very best to limit that pain for
customers and Ian I think that's really
important we try and do that there are
many customers who will be worried about
their new mortgage payments so please
get in get in contact with us we're here
to have the conversation with you we're
here to try and help you through
um but I don't think rates are going to
be falling anytime soon because as you
know Ian this is all linked to inflation
and ended up being more sticky than we
all anticipated all right Ian gotta
leave it there busy day for you do
appreciate you spending the time to chat
thank you pleasure thank you take care
bye
still to come here on your king life why
students are calling for more technology
lessons at school including Esports stay
with us
[Music]
welcome back now if you sometimes
Grumble about the amount of time your
kids spend on playing computer games you
might be better off leaving to them
their own devices research from Dell
Technologies and Intel suggested Esports
holds real value for young people and
helps them develop key skills required
for the world of work the two companies
have now entered a two-year partnership
with the British Esports Federation
aimed at promoting Esports as an
industry fostering 21st century skills
new career Pathways and economic growth
for the UK well with me now are Steve
Young he's managing direct to UK of Dell
Technologies and Chester King he's
founder and chief executive of British
Esports uh welcome to both Steve I mean
my problem with all this is that this is
based on interviews with 11 to 17 year
old students I mean I'm sure if I ask my
kids would you spend more time doing
maths or playing computer games I can
guess what they'd say yeah I think we
could all guess what they'd see here and
the interesting thing so so Dale and
Intel of of Dennis Arabi and and UK
students so 82 percent of them would
like to see more technology in the
curriculum at school and 50 of them
believe that that would lead to better
jobs
now a recent government report states
that 80 of vacancies in the UK right now
need digital skills and then if you also
look at the business element businesses
say one of the inhibitors for their
growth is availability of great talent
so if you take those factors together
the fact that our students want more
technology and both business and
government want to see better digital
skills because they believe it will help
the workforce of the future then I think
we have a unique opportunity to build
that digital Savvy workplace of the
future what I'm taking away from what
you're saying though is that as an
employer a very major employer skill
schools are not really equipping kids
with these skills right now I think the
schools do the best job they can I mean
teachers we all know work really really
hard
but another element to this is that if
we were to set up something like an
Esports
a qualification in schools then I think
the latest report we saw from the
students is that they believe that would
help them with stem with a science
technology their engineering and their
maths as well and as a when I was a
parent of younger children
I probably find it difficult to make the
connection between Esports and stem but
if you look at the way the gameplay you
know the systematic thinking the way
they analyze data the evidence-based
strategies and you add that to the
digital skills that they're enhancing
then I think we're on to something and I
I remember when I was a kid at school a
long time ago I acknowledge
um I was best at the subjects that was
most passionate about so if we can
harness and leverage that passion
that our students have and combine that
with Esports then I think you know we're
building a digital Savvy Workforce of
the future and that's why I'm delighted
that Dell Technologies and British
Esports have announced this partnership
so Jester what would a qualification
look like I mean we should say there's
already a B Tech out there in Esports
yeah so we're just finishing year three
of uh of our b-tech we've had five and a
half thousand students in the UK just
complete it
um but we've got about 50 of Fe
College's doing that what I love about
this research is it's kind of
encouraging schools to kind of look at
Esports as a curriculum and uh you're
probably aware that there's been some
level three reforms anyway so I think
it's perfect timing we've got for
example coming up Olympic Esports week
where we're going to have our country
representing ourselves uh in the
tournament and also we've got the Euro
games but the the beat up at the moment
just gives a whole range of skills that
are transferable not just obviously in
Esports but also into cyber big data and
in the UK the biggest employers Visa
people are actually at the sports
industry so every Formula One team has
an Esports Team every Premier League
team has an Esports team but also going
into kind of the Armed Forces as well
they want people with different skill
sets and Esports and the B Tech that
we're doing delivers that it's the
current generation of school kids more
attuned to this kind of stuff than
previous generations I mean even ones
who maybe only a few years older than
them yeah so what's fantastic is in the
UK from a higher education point of view
we're actually got 14 universities now
you can study Esports and there's a new
university called the College of Esports
in London that's just dedicated to
Esports so yeah really excited I mean
and what about the schools themselves
are they equipped to deliver this yeah
so the classroom you know you most
obviously have a PC and obviously it's
about training the teachers that you
know one could say that the kids know a
lot more than teachers but I think we're
seeing a real appetite and they're
learning you know in our survey I think
it was over 43 of the teachers were
saying that they want to help and
understand about for future employment
you need future skills and you need
future qualifications so there's a real
engagement and the passion you know I
love talking about Esports as an active
media so you've got passive media social
media but for me Sports is a real active
medium when people understand and thank
you for the opportunity they talk about
it you know once people understand about
how positive Esports is and the passion
for these people to learn and use it as
a tool then you know we're doing our job
all right Chester Steve you've got to
leave it there good to talk to you both
this morning thank you thank you
just a reminder of our top breaking
story this hour it's been announced that
Silvio Berlusconi the former Italian
Prime Minister has died at the age of 86
obviously Italy's longest serving
post-war prime minister will have a lot
more on that story coming up after this
short break he was also of course a very
very successful businessman in his own
right prior to entering politics well
Jane sucker is up next with all the
latest reaction to news at silvani
Sylvia billis gunny has passed away I'm
back at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning hope
to see you then cheerio
foreign